béatrice de bast rebonjour directrice
des collections d'été adjointe du
patrimoine du centre national du cinéma
cnc on va parler des archives qui sont
conservés ici à vous et merci mais
d'abord peut-être un mot pour les gens
qui ne savent pas qu est-ce que c'est le
cnc alors le cnc le centre national du
cinéma et de l'image animée
c'est l'institution qui régule et
finance le cinéma mais aussi la création
audiovisuelle les la création de jeux
vidéo est en fait tout ce qui a à voir
avec la création et la diffusion du
visuel et cinématographique c'est un peu
l'institution de ce qu'on appelle
l'exception culturelle française voilà
tout à fait effectivement le cnc très
attaché pour la défense effectivement
d'une création diversifiée en ce qui
concerne le cinéma et l'audiovisuel
alors vous occuper plus spécifiquement
des archives du cinéma français qui sont
donc ici à bois d'arcy
c'est au fond de trésors du cinéma le
voilà on a effectivement des films très
très ancien dont les anciens alors les
plus anciens datent enfin d'heure avant
même la création à l'invention du
cinématographe lumière puisque ce sont
les voilà ce sont des bandes qui réalise
et des bancs d'essai en fait réalisé par
les les pionniers photographes comme
marais comme les photographes anglais
qui s'essayait en fait à mettre en
mouvement des images donc avant
l'arrivée du travail le soir il y avait
déjà le premier film alors c'est
effectivement le premier film de
l'histoire du cinéma enfin pas celui-là
c'est une sortie des usines lumière mais
le les lumières sont les premiers à
avoir trouvé un système qui permet de
filmer et de restituer sur grand écran
là le mouvement la vie
captée par un objectif cinématographe
mais il ya des essais à bord mais il ya
eu beaucoup beaucoup d c est à travers
le à travers le monde mais c'est eux qui
ont en fait inventé la séance de cinéma
publié deux payantes le grand écran la
le rassemblement du public dans la salle
donc c'est incroyable jeudi le trésor
c'est vraiment ça que comme moi par
exemple on va parler des autres films et
comment ces films sont arrivés ici alors
on va les films arrivent ici par
différents
différents circuits
il y a des dépôts d
des producteurs des laboratoires ça
c'est pour les films récents pour les
films
plus anciens comme ça comment société de
production qui existe depuis avant 1900
comme la gaumont pathé que donc on a
effectivement les premiers négatif
gaumont les premiers négatif pathé qui
datent parfois de certains entre 1896 et
puis après il ya des collectionneurs qui
ont rassemblé justement ces essais où
ils les ont gardés mais les ont confiés
à des institutions patrimoniales par
exemple on allait le dépôt du musée
d'orsay qui conserve
ou du cnam
justement c'est premier ses premières
tentatives de mise en mouvement des
images et qui leur ont été confiés pour
le cnam déjà dans les années 30 par des
collectionneurs des personnes qui
souhaitaient justement garder une trace
de cette histoire du cinéma mais les
grandes sociétés de production par les
pattes et moment il garde aussi des
traces de ces films là où c'est vous qui
avez alors ils nous ont confié leur
leurs négatifs
étant donné que nous avons des bâtiments
adaptés à la conservation des films
anciens qui étaient sur un support un
petit peu de vin très dangereux même des
le nitrate de cellulose
qui avait d'excellentes qualités
photogénique qui rendait très très bien
les qualités de l'émulsion
photographique mais qui avait la
fâcheuse tendance à s'enflammer à s'auto
enflammés et qui s'auto consume s'il
n'est pas conservé dans de bonnes dans
de bonnes conditions
l'élu perdre donc d alors il ya eu il ya
eu de grands incendies effectivement
dans les différents stocks ont été
entreposés au cours de l'histoire le
matériel cinématographique mais
certaines sociétés de production ont
organisé elle-même des autodafés à une
époque où on n'avait pas cette
conscience du patrimoine
cinématographique et c'est fini c'est
voilà pourtant ce quoi pour éliminer les
vieux films bas on et détruisez on l'est
on les brûle et ça c'est je vous parle
des années dit c'est comme ça aussi
qu'il ya des lacunes en fait dans
l'histoire du cinéma parce que voilà on
a volontairement si vous voulez détruit
pour céder certaines sociétés de
production comme éclipse ou luxe sur les
sociétés aujourd'hui oubliée il ya eu
cette volonté si vous voulez de faire de
la place sur le marché en éliminant les
bandes qu'on pensait que les spectateurs
n'aurais plus envie de voir ce qui était
passée était finie que quand vous dites
alors voilà nous on a les moyens de les
conserver ça veut dire quoi il ya
plusieurs bâtiments voilà le cnc a
aménagé petit à petit le site dans de
bois d'arcy kevin une ancienne batterie
militaire et on a construit des
bâtiments spéciaux pour ses films aux
nitrates qui sont des bâtiments de la
petite petite volumétrie qui contiennent
à peu près 1500 boîte de films ce qui
permet en fait en cas d' incendies
puisque c'est un flux en plus qu'on ne
peut pas étendre quel que soit votre
guise et l'harmonie au privation
d'oxygène ça continue à brûler donc on
réduit le nombre en fait deux films
stockés dans un même espace si j'avais
il y avait un problème pour limiter dans
cette période voilà et puis après alors
donc ces petites petites unités avec une
température constante et un taux
d'hygrométrie également constant et
ensuite ont été bâtis des
déconstructions des silos qui permettent
de conserver les films sur support de
sécurité acétate trier s'est hâté
aujourd'hui polyester donc il y en a
trois sur le site de batz type de bois
d'arcy l'eau et puis nous avons
également des bâtiments sur le site du
fort de saint cyr mais voilà vous parlez
du nitrate par exemple il n'y a pas
d'autres moyens il faut les conserver
tel quel il n'ya pas y'a pas moyen de
les mettre sur un autre challenge qu'a
fait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on numérise ses films pour
pouvoir les les diffuser puisque les les
salles de cinéma sont aujourd'hui dotés
d'appareils de projection numérique donc
il faut que ces films trouvent d un
support
pour être divisés mais la conservation
elle se fait toujours sur support
support argentique puisque c'est le
support que l'on sait conserver à long
terme parce que le numérique on ne sait
pas on va voilà le numérique aujourd'hui
bon c'est pas le blogueur de voile a
peur on n'a pas de
système si vous voulez fiable que l'on
peut
adopter pour conserver si vous voulez à
coup sûr sur voilà une centaine ou 300
ans comme l'offre en fait la pellicule
polyester alors il ya une ou plusieurs
étapes pendant le sommeil aujourd'hui
c'est de 16 mm mais le 33 alors il y à
il ya eu effectivement nombre de formats
en plus si on ajoute les les formats
réduits qui est utilisé les amateurs
effectivement ça fait beaucoup de
formats qu'il faut savoir traiter avec
la mission des archives ces deux aussi
de créer des outils qui permettent de
pouvoir traiter ces films donc au cnc
nous avons développé un scanner tout à
fait
prototype qui nous permet justement de
prendre en compte les films anciens
du 8 mm aux 90 mm ce qui était souvent
la largeur des idées banque justement de
demarest
donc est alors au tout ça fait combien
combien de films alors que nous avons la
chance de conserver à peu près cent dix
mille titres sorti qu est ce qui fait un
volume d'à peu près un million cent
mille boîtes
donc fait effectivement dès la 2
l'espace et des locaux et vous recevez
je crois 1000 films chaque année 1 au
moins 1000 films chaque année alors que
ce soit et par effectivement les dépôts
de producteurs de laboratoires de
collectionneurs mais aussi
par le dépôt légal puisque le public
visites et voilà du du dépôt légal et il
y a obligation un dépôt de copies ou
d'éléments intermédiaire encore
aujourd'hui malgré que le fait que la
numérisation du cinéma pour assurer la
pérennité effectivement des oeuvres
contemporaines puisque en fait nous
conservons le passé du cinéma mais nous
ouvrons aussi pour l'avenir pour que les
générations futures puissent avoir accès
au cinéma que nous faisons aujourd'hui
justement cpl avec et se veut opposer et
ses trésors qui est ici type peut y
avoir accès alors ce que n'importe qui
peut arriver là j'aurais voir un nom
d'un père qu il faut alors quand on est
si vous voulez un particulier et il faut
être chercheur de mentalist est à voir
si vous voulez une raison
professionnelle on va dire pour accéder
aux collections mai
nous sommes en rapport étroit bien
évidemment avec les ayants droit nous
ont confié ce matériel et nous
travaillons avec eux sur la restauration
des filles et sur la circulation des
oeuvres une fois qu'elles ont été
restaurés ou voilà si nous avons du
matériel d'une bonne bonne et a même
qu'un dix ou vingt ans pour organiser la
circulation de ce matériel
cinématographique dans le cadre de
festivals de prendre infection mais
aussi on travaille à l'édition à faire
avec eux à l'édition de dvd la mise la
mise en ligne sur des plateformes de vod
ou une voix diffusion télévisuelle
puisque pour que les gens s'y voit
notre rôle est de fabriquer si vous
voulez des supports qui permettent en
fait au cinéma de diffuser le plus
largement possible vous dire que c'est
la mémoire du cinéma ici dans tout à
fait
assumée du cinéma français mais aussi de
signaler tous y voit là puisque l'on y
voit des films français des collections
de films américains anglais et chinois
tout à fait tout à fait étonnant et
souvent nous avons aussi des films qui
nous sont confiés par des collègues
étrangers pour que nous en fassions la
restauration parce qu'il ya des ddd lieu
identique à l'étranger d'aborder des
gens c'est elle c'est alors le cnc est
une effectivement une
l'institution que beaucoup de pays
envient et envier à la france puisque
c'est vrai que ça permet de au cinéma de
dettes refinancées d'être
organisée et en ce qui concerne les
archives alors il ya de grandes archives
par exemple en russie aux etats-unis il
ya plusieurs centres oscille archives en
italie en angleterre également mais
effectivement il ya beaucoup de pays
notamment dans les pays émergents où ses
structures en fait archivistique
n'existe pas ou ont beaucoup de mal à
ceux à se créer et nous arrive de faire
des missions pour aider au rôle voilà
voilà pour aider à la constitution de
ces archives dans les différents pays
qui ont des cinématographies et pour
lesquels c'est très important pour
l'identité de chaque pays d'avoir cette
mémoire cinématographique et
audiovisuelle à disposition merci
infiniment maîtrise de béatrice de
pastres devoir présenter ce dieu qui est
quand même